Next up let's have a look at render targets. So what is a render target? Well a render target
is a material which you can find and create from within the textures panel here.
I've got something that's called a render target and what it is is it will allow you to
write to this material at runtime. So usually we would do this from a camera
and I'll demonstrate how we do that in a second but let's first see the kind of effect that we've got.
So here you go we've got this TV here and as I move around this actor with the camera
on the right-hand side here you can see that the the TV is changing. So
I'll just demonstrate that a bit further so you can see at runtime as the camera moves
the texture is updating on the television set. So what we have is this actor here if I open this up
and see how this is set up and it's quite straightforward. There is no actual code which
is required at this point. It's all done through a component and the component is the
scene capture component 2d and once we've got that we've got a number of different settings.
So I could just add that by going add scene capture, scene capture component 2d, add it to
the components. It's got a couple of different settings on here and the main ones that you'll
be worried about is the texture target. So this is the render target so what it's going to be saving to
and what we have next to it as well one of the other bits that's really really useful
is capture every frame. Now these can be costly because if they are taking a photo every single
frame then you're basically rendering the whole scene twice so you can be like almost doubling
the the cost of rendering your scene so you have a camera miles away it's gonna have to
render everything that that camera can see. So there are other options you can either do it
programmatically so you tell it when you want to update or you can just capture on movement by
turning that off. Capture on movement I think is what I'm using throughout here to keep the cost
down. So we have the render target and you don't even think we need the camera and here
we can see it in the material setup. So I am just using the render target as a texture sample
and I'm plugging it through the emissive colour. Now the render target here if I was to open this
up you'll see that we have some options one of the main ones is the size because this is
going to be the size of your texture so in this I've kept it quite small so that it all
runs pretty fast but they can get bigger if you make them too big they will give you a warning.
The other thing that's worth noting back up to the render target is at the moment I'm capturing
the scene colour but you do have a number of different options so I'll demonstrate those
I'll demonstrate one in a minute you've got things like normals the base colour final colour
much like when we're working with scene textures but it's got quite a limited number.
Right so this is one example where you'd be able to show TV screens or something as you're
going around let's have a look at a more common example and that is a mini map so if I was to
fire this up and press play you can now see in the bottom corner here I have a mini map
as I run through the level it will update accordingly depending on where my character is
situated so now how this is done is again we're doing it very similar to our last example
we have a mini map camera here which has a all it has is the scene capture component 2d
I'm then using event tick in order to make sure that the camera is moving with the character but
the main thing that's of interest is the capture source I'm using is the scene depth
in r so that will give me in the red column it's just going to give me the scene depth so
we've worked with scene depth before and this is in centimeters so when I would look at this
you would see that it just looks like it's solid red because everything that it's logging back
is in very high values but only in the red only in the red channel now you can see here
we have the minim so if I jump in to see the mini map here all we're doing is taking the
texture sample and again we're dividing it so that we've got some kind of useful value
and I'm using a cut off just so that we can get an either a zero or a one so that we can get that
nice clean that now you don't have to use the depth you could easily use just a screenshot
from above if you wanted a more realistic type but that's what I've decided to use in this
instance and again we so we're using a UMG to display this and I'm just using the material
on a image and in front of it as well I've got another image which I'm updating the rotation
of it based on the rotation of the player character just so that we have that arrow which
is alternating as we move so I'm just demonstrating this I'm not going to ask
you to put it together but but that's how you might approach making a mini map
so that's render targets very useful as a source of something to write to as we're going along